Okay
I was up at 2:00 a.m.
So the first thing
That I've noticing is that there are a lot
of other agents
Messages
Being sent to agent number one so that lets
me know that the validation system for the
messaging system is either not working
broken or has been removed
Since we need to go in and we need to fix
that
And then I also have to go through all eight
agents
Threads to see exactly what happened like I
let them run
For an extended amount of time so
I'm hoping that I can gather more insights
into how I can make this autonomous
development more streamlined and easy
CuzAt this point I can consistently get them
working.
For hours on end I can go to sleep and
they'll continue running so it's no longer
about continuing them running or keeping
them going and and I've done it and it even
better way than I started cuz at first I had
a overnight script that would randomly send
a message that just said continue working
but now the messages should be more
efficient because
They are just direct messages between the
agents the problem currently is that
WhenThe agents work. They tend to.
Duplicate.
OverComplicate. And.
Just generate a lot of AI slop
And those are the things that I have to
address in the next
Cycle before I can really just send them to
work autonomously again but it was exciting
to see the agents
Create
Or recreate the Discord commander and I
wasn't here for that like I think that is
the most amazing thing about this system and
I can't wait to see how the agents
distribute it or if the captain decided to
take it upon its own hands like
And I was literally autonomous development I
drove to work and got a message that my my
stuff was working
I'm going forward
We seek to increase efficiency in the
development workflows we seek to
Solve the complexities ofThings like.
The message routing and not the message
right and then I spoke up before this time
I'm speaking or referring to the fact that
if the captain agent broadcast
Message to the Swarm then he will
effectively send off eight messages
When each agent receives this message they
will message the captain back
If they messaged if they all message the
captain back
The captain gets one response at a time and
each one of them cues so what we then have
is eight
Two eight messagesEight messages in the
captain's. Message queue and so.
Over time this becomes a bigger
It becomes a gap and it's a problem because
let's say after those eight agents sent the
acknowledgment message to the captain they
went off and they sent the message to
another agent to get to work then those
agents don't have anything in their queue
they only had one so agent one is on cycle
one Asian one sends a message to agent for
and that message to agent too agent 2 sends
a message to agent for again because of his
own board and message and then he'll send a
message back to agent one because he'll have
that message in his q and he'll be able to
respond now in that same time frame
Agent for will have received eight messages
and have to respond to each one of them
individually what I need to do is to try to
try to create something where multiple
agents can message one
All the agents can respond to a single point
and then after all the agents have responded
it's send that to the captain so it receives
all the agents responses at once
And that way we could possibly keep a better
track of the Cycles I don't know if this
will work but that's where my mind's taking
me so the next couple of days of development
will be starting to push towards there I see
The light at the end of the tunnel with this
project and I can definitely feel like we're
going to get this thing up and running oh
another thing I wanted to mention I was
looking through the logs at some of the
threads they there was a situation where
okay so first what prompted it was I started
a competition series because the
competitions when you send the agents to
work proactively in a competition based
environment they tend to thrive so that's
the move clearly that's the move you set
them to a competition you put things toward
you put weight towards points that way you
can make a priority system based off of what
you want so if you want something done like
for instance let's say I really wanted the
Discord Commander done I put it at 10,000
points as soon as an agent sees that they
will start going home and trying to get that
done first one gets it done complete the
order you see
Or complains the order and they start they
can break it down into multiple points or
maybe I should add that is where if a big
test something like that is worth 10,000
points then agents could break it down into
smaller Point projects
But the idea is to use that as a way to let
the captain know when we have
CompletedThe project.
I can give more details on that later but I
only brought that up just to say I forgot
give me a second I got to pump the ashes I
just dropped it load on you
Sorry Mama
You can buy diamonds with Roblox bro
Yeah alien class cost like 900
Which is the one that cost $900 Charlie
Bro you capping one of them cost y'all right
You know it don't really matter cuz at the
end of the day even if you was right you
still going to
You still going to be ugly and you got to
live with that forever it's nothing you
could do about that okay
Yeah but I rather be ugly than have asthma
I said thatOh you're right.
Opposite day in January 25th is January 5th
Oh yeah so that's why I brought it up I
remember now I remember okay so the reason
why I brought up the competition is because
agent 7 won the competition
Agent 7 I'm assuming gave a matter of fact
why are we assuming anything when we got the
file it up for you
Give me a second I just got to switch the
screen over here let's go here we'll meet
this one you can see okay let's go up and
see what happened with
Matter of fact Let me show my face y'all
y'all ain't seen my face in a minute
It's still ugly don't don't get it
twistedSweet Chris get it from he look just
like.
He'll know it but he really my son
It don'tShut up why you always got to
correct me when I say that.
Dang y'all literally been doing that my
whole life we'll be going to the store like
these my kids though that's my step daddy
You're oh really so I wouldn't be at the at
the grocery store shopping for food and
being into somebody else babies
Now I know you just heard me call that lady
your mother fucking
I already know uglyLie see the main
corporate.
CourtCorporate.
I just wanted to seeI know I got to work.
Another funny thing about being right Chris.
Even if you're rightYou still ugly.
I don't knowYou give me in trouble when you
don't do your school work that's not really
cool.
And you still ugly on top of that
You only pull Zoe and she got a potty mouth
that make you garbage
I hope y'all didn't kiss cuz she got a party
nowYou did KISS it didn't now you got a
potty mouth.
Good good
Where you replaceReplace Zoey with Javion.
Okay we'll take Zoe back I'm sorry what I
said I like Zoe that's my best friend I'mma
had her own Roblox bro don't don't go that
way just because I don't like throat Zoe bro
it's okay it's okay we like Zoe we like Zoey
no no no fuck no no no no no no no
It's okayWhat.
Oh and Javion just your play brother
ElaineElaine.
Is it going to embarrass me today I think
it's going to open right up
I'd put my money on me too broDid they open
right up no.
On
1250 Charlie 60 70
And nobody to talkAlone so fast.
And it works
I wish you could attended here
In
It's hardNot me. Bodyguard blue body parts.
Moving parts
I told you butHope he's a lot better.
Stop
What up
So much
Who's your dog
QuotesI'm.
Sonoma kids